you gave a presentation earlier today
about data analytics next big thing in
FTTH tell us what were the main
highlights you what you were mentioning
to the conference today okay the decay
time presented was how operators FTTH
operators but also mobile operators use
data analytics to improve the planning
the forecasting the predictive
maintenance of the networks so basically
improving their by their asset
utilization and improving their by their
roi on their networks as a important
asset why is it so important in FTTH I
know data analytics is something that
we've been used to for several years
with mobile but this is quite a new
concept in FTTH yes well we all know the
investments need it for a network
rollout of FTT eight are sometimes quite
substantial so therefore the
shareholders or the owners they want to
have a decent return on investment and
that can be done by analytics by
understanding the the uptake of cable by
the uptake of fiber and the traffic
flowing over it but also for improving
the customer experience management how
do the end-users the your customers
experience the services you provide and
again that can be done with data
analytics for understanding that better
for delivering a better service how are
you seeing the market at the moment
there seems to be a real uptake of FTTH
at the moment right across Europe yes
yes and you see a number of operators
small large operators here in Europe and
that's I think for the customer very
good news there are increasing their
investments in fiber and other related
technologies to provide better services
to the customers a broader bandwidth for
customers getting more a new advanced
services so i think that's that's great
news again the the topic will be how do
you keep the quality of service of those
services and the customer experience
management of your services up to date
and to a certain standard so therefore
again
analytics will be very important in
doing that and you're currently really
specialize in that tell us a bit about
SES well SAS is a analytics company
we're around for 40 odd years in the
business where the number one when it
comes to analytics worldwide in terms of
the market share in analytics and we
provide services to all sorts of
industries ranging from public finance
banking insurance companies but also
telecommunications operators big and
small so that they can plan their
investments and their network better
which I oh thanks very much for joining
us Thank You Ryan